[Music]
well CRISPR is an acronym that actually
represents a sequence of DNA letters in
the in the genomes of cells it's found
in bacteria and it's a it's was
interesting to scientists originally
because it's a bacterial immune system a
way that bacteria can fight viral
infection but the CRISPR acronym has now
become widespread in the media as a as a
an indication of a new technology for
gene editing and the story of how an
adaptive immune system in bacteria was
harnessed as a technology for gene
editing is really part of what a crack
in creation is about so the CRISPR gene
editing technology is a tool that
scientists can use to change the letters
of DNA in cells in precise ways so I
like to use the analogy of a word
processor on our computer so we have a
document so you can think about the DNA
and a cell like the text of a document
that has the instructions to tell the
cell how to grow and divide and become a
brain cell or a liver cell or develop
into an entire organism and it just like
in a document the CRISPR technology
gives scientists a way to go in and edit
the letters of DNA just like we might
cut and paste text in our in our
document or replace whole sentences even
even whole paragraphs or chapters we can
now do that using the CRISPR technology
in the DNA itself so when we think about
a technology that allows precise changes
to DNA to be made you know for
scientists this is sort of a you know a
really a gift that allows research to
proceed very quickly in terms of
understanding the genetics of cells and
organisms but also provides a very
practical way to solve problems and
there's a there's a many that we could
discuss but I'll mention a couple that I
think are particularly exciting so in in
clinical medicine the opportunity to may
changes to blood cells that would cure
diseases like sickle cell anemia disease
where you know we've understood the
genetic cause for a long time but until
now there hasn't been a way to actually
think about treating patients and now
with this technology it's possible in
principle to remove stem cells that give
rise to blood cells in a person's body
make edits to those cells that would
correct the mutation causing sickle cell
disease and then replace those cells to
essentially give a patient a new a new
set of cells that don't have the defect
so I think that's very exciting and
there are multiple research groups right
now working on doing just that so I
think that's a future you know probably
sometime in the next two to five years
we will see clinical trials in that area
and we hope real progress towards curing
that disease but there's a you know
another example that I think is also
very potentially very impactful
clinically but it has a very different
kind of strategy is the idea of making
edits to pigs to create animals that are
going to be better organ donors for
humans and so pigs are already of
interest for for organ donation but
imagine that we could make edits to the
DNA of pigs to make their organs more
human-like and also to remove any
viruses from pig cells that might
otherwise infect a patient and those are
both things that are actively underway
using the CRISPR technology and then a
third area that I think is interesting
to think about from the perspective of
global impact in disease is thinking
about using gene editing not to not to
change the DNA and people per se but
actually to affect the kinds of insects
that transmit disease to people and the
idea here is that one could use a gene
editor to create mosquitoes that would
be unable to transmit viruses like
dengue virus or Zika virus by using a
technique called gene drive that allows
traits to be
read very quickly through a population
using an efficient way of gene editing
such as the the CRISPR tool and I think
that's an opportunity that you know
could have very big impact in in terms
of global health but also requires
obviously some you know very thorough
vetting and discussion about potential
environmental impact I think one of the
the aspects of this technology that's
been very interesting to me personally
is my own kind of personal growth
through the last few years I think that
you know when I started this research
project which actually began now almost
10 years ago in the lab we were
certainly not thinking about technology
that would allow alteration of human
evolution or anything of that nature
and over the last few years when as this
technology has begun to be deployed
globally in different for different
applications I have found that I have
gone from you know thinking about it
initially just with you know sort of
almost you know wide-eyed excitement
thinking about all the opportunities
that this offers to realizing that you
know there was real risk and that that
we really needed we meaning the
scientific community and really frankly
the the human community needed to be
aware of this and discussing it and one
of the things that that sort of brought
that to the forefront of my mind was a
dream that I had fairly early on in
which I was you know I walked into a
room and a colleague of mine said to me
Jennifer I'd like you to explain the
CRISPR technology to a friend and he
brought me into a room and there a
person was sitting with their back to me
and as they turned around I realized was
sort of a horror horror that it was it
was Hitler and it was actually Hitler
with a sort of a pig nose and it almost
looked like a chimeric pig human sort of
sort of creature and it was it was you
know it sounds funny and a way to relate
that image but in the dream it was a
terrifying thing and I
really felt real just you know
stone-cold fear in the dream and sort of
woke up from that dream with a start and
realized you know kind of had this
initial feeling of what what have I done
you know and and that was really one of
the things that that that motivated me
to you know to get out of the lab and
start talking to people more broadly
about the technology about capabilities
about the great things about it but also
about things that really required really
deep thought and careful consideration
and regulation
[Music]
you